一応 まあ一応こういう風にあったとすると
そこでドーサキャリタの番目怒りですか
瞋ですか 瞋恚の人 が来たらちょっと住所を書いてくれませんかと言ったら
いろいろ方法はあるかもしれませんだけど
前の人と同じ説明するならば
その人も座って書くとするならば
この人来て 一応今わかるでしょ
結果としてもどうなったかと
自分が座って書く場所を確保する
で そこでこの これはドーサキャリタの人をやって
でモーハキャリタの人の場合
またデモンストレーションやるのは嫌なんですけど
で モーハキャリタの人にはこっちに座って住所を書いてくださいと言ったら
大体ああいう風にこんな感じなんですね
で なんぼこのまま座ってみるかもしれませんしね
こうやって で とにかくそこをあまり全然ここら辺が変化しません
困っちゃうんですね ここで書けませんだからという感じで
で それ一つそこだけで決めると
だから文字の書き方ね
で いろいろあるんです
一旦一応ラーガ・ドーサ・モーハキャリタはそうやって見過ぎ
いくらかこれぐらい人間の人格はきっちりと決まっているならばわかるんです
でも難しいのはラーガとモーハが組み合わさっている
モーハとドーサが組み合わさっている
ラーガとドーサが組み合わさっている
これはやりきれないんですよ
判断相当難しい そこでラーガのラーガキャリタあります
貪の貪の性格 瞋の瞋もあります
で 例えば貪瞋痴 モーハキャリタは何書いてます？痴
この痴の痴であって 痴の痴
さらによくある人もいるんです
だからそこもあれもやりたい
これもやりたいと でも一つもできない
例えば勉強しないんだけど
ちゃんと本は持っている
このなんとかなんとか世界世界史でしょう
これはもうなんとか先生の本も私は全部セット持ってますよと
そうやって大学の教授のサインは持ってますけど
勉強したことはないと
そういう性格もありますね
例えば同じ大学に入ったとする
入ったらすぐ先生と仲良くなる
先生のカバン持って毎日家まで行くんだけど
勉強まるっきりゼロやと
そこで先生に授業中いろいろ悪口言ったりとか
陰で先生の落書き漫画描いたりとかね
したってもきちんと勉強する人もいるんです
あの人の家には絶対行きませんよと言いながら喧嘩までしながら
でも勉強する性格の人もいて
先生に毎日先生のカバンを持って家まで見送りして自分の家に帰る学生もいるかもしれませんし
そういうことをやるんだけど
学問は全くゼロで そこで彼がこの無知の性格なんですけど
欲もありますから この欲でそれは乗るんですね
天気乗り そこで先生はあれまで奴隷みたいにいろいろなことをやってくれると
なんとかしてくれる してあげる
そこでなんとかしてあげたら
真面目に勉強した学生たちに
あんたらどうですかね
先生の奥様は昨日風邪ひいて
私はこうやったんですとかね
そこで私はその先生は明日外国で研究発表に行くんだからね
まあ僕を洗濯屋さんからね
ちゃんと運んであげて
この資料とか全部整理してあげて
ああだこうだともうすごい個人盤までして
すごい自分の茶柱作っちゃいますけど
でももう何もわかりませんね
勉強したことも何もないんだから
そういう人々は まあ私はこの勉強したんだからね
そういう環境でいろいろ見てきたんだから
皆様もっと幅広い人生を送ってきたんだから
もっとそういう人々は知ってるかもしれません
だからこの基本的には知性で知性
知の知性なんですけど
知の知性でプラスすごく入ってるんですね
トンセでも それでそういう性格に見えるんです
例えば あなたはなんでそんなにアホなのに博士号を持って持ってますかと
これまでバカのに なんでオックスフォード大学卒業ですかと
わからないでしょうに
まあ大学卒業はいるかどうか分かりませんんだけど
まあ個人的には知らないんです
まあオックスフォード大学とかケーンウッドとかいるんですからね
だから不思議でしょ こんなに間抜けないアホなのにオックスフォード大学卒業ですねとか
思ったりすることもありましたからね
だから だからそこでどういう性格
本当にこれは頭のいい人かどうかっていうことよりは
そこでいろいろこの複雑な
むさぼりがあって 怒りもあって
ああだこうだとか だから基本的に
例えば知性 知性の人が知性があって
それにプラスして欲もあると
プラスして怒りもあると
そこで怒りあるでしょ
この怒りは怒りで見えます
怒りっていうのは この野郎
ああだこうだ言ったら怒ることだから
そうやって見えない この怒りは知性だから
この人怒っているか落ち込んでるかわからないんですね
自分でもわからない 自分が怒っているかということさえ
だから他人にもわかりにくいんですね
なぜかというと 性格のもともとは知性だから
そこで欲があるでしょうね
欲っていうのは これすごく綺麗だから私に来れませんか？とかね
そういう明確な性格なんですね
人のものでも これこれ私が気に入ったんだから取ったぞと
もらったよと もう強引に持っていくとかね
それでわかりやすいね
まあいつに見られたらもう終わりだから鍵かけておきましょうと
もうなんか気に入ったら持っていくんだからと
そういう性格だったら
欲の抑制だとはっきりするんですね
だから私たちもどういう対策すればいいかとハッキリしているんですね
ほんのちょっと事で怒鳴って怒る人だったら
まあこの人はまあもう歩く原子爆弾だから
まあ気をつけましょうと
いつでも あの 何ていうなまりの板を立てて
その後ろにしましょうということでわかるでしょ
欲張り屋の性格だったら
まあもう玄関で話をして
そのまま返せばいいでしょうし
家の中に入ったらなんか気に入ったもの取っていっちゃうんだと
ですから 性格明確に明確だったら
まあ対策もわかりますけど
問題は例えば知性で怒りもあって
プラスアルファでも欲もあるんだというと
この人怒っているかと本人もわからないし
こっちもわからない そこですごく欲が出てくる
例えば ある人の家に行ったら
その家でかなりの立派な何か置物があるんだと
これ自分が気に入ったと
気に入ったんだけど これわからないんですね
これいいものだから あの
どこで買ったんですかと
で 何もわからない それもそうじゃなくて
これ欲しい その代わりにその人が欲しいんだから
頭も悪いんだから もしかすると同じ似ている他のものを
買ってくるかもしれません
買ってあなたにプレゼント持ってきましたよと
だからこの人はこれもらったら自分の家にある置物これはこれただの安物で
そこら辺に置いておけばいいかもしれませんだけど
そこら辺置いとくかもしれませんし
あの人はだからこういう置物をもらったんだから
じゃあお返しに あれなんですけど
じゃあこれもらってくださいと
これもしくれたらいいなとか計算するかもしれません
そんなことありえないでしょうね
結局自分が損しただけなんですね
だから逆にこのプレゼントもらった人は
この人もなかなか優しい人やと
欲のない人やと お金もないのにこんなプレゼント持ってきたんだからと
私には別にもう価値がないんだけど
やっぱりせっかくもらったものだからと置いておきますよということになるでしょうに
だからこちらも誤解しているんです
あの人は結構人にプレゼントあげたがる人やと
本当は逆なんです すごく物欲しい人なんです
物欲しい人だけど 性格基本的に無知だから
この欲しいものを得るために変な手段を使っただけなんです
そこでもらったところか
持ってきたものはなくなったと
結果として だからそこで問題が
この本人も自分がどんな性格かハッキリしていない
他人もわからなくなっちゃうんですね
時々いるでしょ？すごくニコニコしている人々がいて
なんか楽しがっているなと思って勘違いして
その人と話したりやったりするんだけど
どうもおかしいと 後でものすごくカンカンその人を怒っていたんで怒っていたんだと
後で気がつくんですね
そういう風に失敗するんです
なぜかというと この本人さえも自分が笑っているか怒っているか分かってないんだから
まあそういうことで この性格っていうのはまあ理解するんです
簡単でしょ？理解するのは
理解したらその性格に合う瞑想法があります
今 3つ言いましたね  ラーガチャリタ
ドーサチャリタ モーハチャリタ
貪性 瞋性 痴性 で また三つあります
これはサッダーチャリタ
ブッダチャリタ ヴィタッカチャリタ
これでこのサッダーっていうのは瞋でしょう
言葉いいんだからで性格がいいと勘違いしてはいけません
それは単なる性格なんですね
ブッダチャリタは何でしたっけ
覚性 瞋性 で この瞋性っていうのは
あの 本当は貪性とほとんど同じ
性格は あの またデモンストレーションするっていうものはやめますけど
あの こんなコントロールで
あの 住所を書いてくださいといったところで
もしかすると瞋性の人も
あの貪性の人がやるように同じことをやるかもしれません
同じくこれ片付いて時計も片付いて
もうこうやって綺麗にしっかりしておいて住所を書く
そこでどうやって判断できますかね？瞋性か瞋性か
この瞋性の人が やっぱりとにかく綺麗で
見た目綺麗でかっこよくでなければ気が済まないんです
ああ これこれ こんな感じ
ダメですよ これちゃんちゃんとこうなって
今綺麗でしょうと だからもう何となく几帳面というか
神経質って 神経質ってちょっと言いにくいんだけど
まあどちらも真面目ではないんだけどね
これどちらも真面目じゃない
とにかくそういう性格なんですね
とにかくかっこよくあればいいということで
瞋性の進行型の人はそうではなくて
やっぱりこういう風にやった方がもっといいでしょう
あの こうこうあるよりはね
まあこういう風にやってるといいんじゃないかという
もうちょっと あの ちょっとまともなんですね
まあとりあえず感じでね
とりあえずあ こちらで書くんですか？じゃあとりあえずついでに片付けておきましょうね
綺麗にとか 本当は本人がやっぱり綺麗にやってほしいです
けど だからってああだこうだ
まあまあついでにじゃあじゃあまあ片付けておいて
で じゃあ住所を書いておきましょう
そこでその人の仕事の場合は
やっぱり住所も書いてあげるんだけど
同時にこの副 何て言いますか
副産物としていい結果も残ってるんですね
[笑い]そうやってまあまあほんのちょっと明るいというかね
そう すごい微妙なんです
信生っていうのは これもっとあの信仰型
信じやすい で この性格っていうのは
まあ日本人の場合はほとんど
それは別に批判的に言うわけじゃなくて
私真面目に言ってるんですけど
日本人は一応こういう風に言っては仏教では全くもう把握できない話は仏教で言わないんだからね
何々さんが信型という言わなくちゃいけないんですけど
一応大雑把で見ると 日本の社会っていうのはこの信仰型なんですね
だから仕事は綺麗に整理する
部屋の内のどっちでも
会社の中でも この何だかんでもすごく見た目いかに綺麗に見えるかというところはよく気にするんです
だからといってすっごい欲張りやというとそうでもないんです
犠牲的になりたいんです
犠牲的になりたい すごく気持ちいいんです
犠牲的になるのは本当は怒り方なんですけど
違うでしょ やっぱり壊すんじゃなくて
ものはしっかりまあ整理して置いておく
犠牲にはなりたい それはかっこいいんです
犠牲になる そこで一番判断できるポイントは自分で判断できない
みんなそうなんです 総理
偉大なる総理大臣閣下からホームレスさんまで
自分で判断できないんです
どうこの場合 いわゆるそれあの悪く悪口で取っちゃえば悪口になっちゃいますけど
このもっと明るい目で取っちゃえば
自分で判断できないっていうのはこの汚い言葉なんですけど
本当はみんなおっしゃる通りにやるんです
それだけ 言葉入れ替えるだけなんですけど
自分で判断できないというと
ちょっと悲観的な言葉でじゃなくて
ちゃんと言われる通りにしっかりやる
ということは人を信じるんです
他人を 他人を信じるということは
自分では何も判断できないということでもある
それで他人を信じるということは
大体人生の中で結構落とし穴に落とされると
だからかなり失敗する
人生の中ではね ものすごい大胆な失敗もする
しても この罠を仕掛けた人は裏切りません
だからその不思議な性格のように見えますけど
これは仏教から見れば大雑把に言えば信生型の民宿なんです
ですから個人個人では別よ
別ですけど まあそういうふうなことで
だからいいか悪いかちょっと言いにくいんです
まあ一応そういう人間ですよと
性格だから これはこの差別ではないんです
区別学なんです  AとBと区別する学であって
差別する学ではないんです
あの貪りのやり方 例えば貪りっていうのは
このユダヤの人々もものすごい欲深いんです
強力なんです 強力に欲深いんだけど
人種として判断するならば
二つに分け怒り方もいて
そちらこの陣ありますね
人生人生ですね だから人生と死同じ漢字発音も同じですけど
人生 人生二つ怒り方と人生ということで
あのよく絡んでいる性格ですから
日本人よりすごい複雑で整理ができる
[笑い]2つですけど
凶暴になると まああの
やっぱりこの民衆としてをやっているのは
今まあ分かりやすく理解しやすいかもしれませんけどね
根本は個人個人がそれでも違います
で エトセトラです  2番サッガーチャリタ
ブッディチャリタ ブッディチャリタっていうのは覚醒ですね
覚醒っていうのは このブッディっていうのは knowledge wisdom なんですね
いわゆる wisdom 型知識型なんですね
知識型かっこいいんでしょ？でも性格としては別にかっこいいでも悪いでもどっちでもないんです
知識型だからといって知識人という意味じゃないんです
信仰型と言ったんだから
信仰深い立派に信頼できる人っていうわけじゃないんです
だからあの覚醒と言ったんだから
覚醒は早いんだという意味ではないんです
ただその型だけ だからどうやってその人を理解するかというと
怒りの人と同じなんです
例えばこちらで住所を書いてくれていたら
これをこうやってやって
これこのマイキーのもの落ちたでしょうに
だってそんなもん言えませんでしょ
そちらには 余計なことをここらに置いて
こっちでも余計なものを置いて
こんなものは使わないんだから
どこかにタンスの中でもどこでも置いてもう放っておけば置いておけばいいのにと
あるいはじゃあなんであんたはこうやって 1発でこうやってこうやったんですか？その方が早いでしょ
いちいちいちいちこっちでもう測りで測ってみたりとかね
やっぱり物は一番早くやった方がいいんだと
こうやってなんか理屈っぽく
合理っぽく 知識っぽく見えます
でも大雑把に性格は怒り方に似ている
そうやってもう何でも合理的っぽく論理的っぽく詰めようとするんだけど
結果としてはガタガタガタガタガタガタで
もうむちゃむちゃ ということ
これは純粋に覚醒だからね
純粋覚醒な人はいません
あの六識外道の中ではいたんだけどね
純粋覚醒で それでさっぱり何もわからないんだと
結果としては だから覚醒型だからいろんな知識型でしょうね
いろんなことわかる 純粋知識型になっちゃったら
あまりに知識的になったところで何もわからないんだと
結果そうなっちゃうんです
だから判断できませんから
まあそういう風には言えないわけないんだけど
でもこれとこれとこれと考えるとちょっと違うでしょう？ということなんです
それであなたは何言いたいんですかと
でもこの子の方まだ考えてないんだから
僕何とも言えないんだということで終わっちゃう
そうやってあれでこれでああだこうだとか
もうでもいい加減でもないんですけど
結果としてはいい加減になっちゃう
で 怒っているように見えるんだけど
その人は怒ってないんです
それは覚醒型 そこでこの次はこの
沈静ですか 人生人という感じなんですけど
この考える性格 この人生の人と知性の人は似ているんですね
そこはこの 例えばこの知性の人にこちらで座って住所を書いてくださいったら
何もわからなくても待ってるでしょうね
スローモーションなんですね
で こうやってうーんしこう見て
まあゆっくり座って こちら紙があるんだから
その上何もすることはできないし
だからというふうなことなんですけど
そうやって遅いんですね
そこで人生の人も遅いんです
よく考えるんです 頭で妄想するみたいなものなんですね
だからこちら この人はこれをこうこうやって置いてるんだから
まあでもだからこれ置いとくとどこに置いておいたらわからないし
で 結局行動は遅くなって判断がしにくくなるようなものになるんですね
だから あの時々いるでしょう
この無口な人々 言葉少ない
ちょっと叩いてみると
頭の中でかなり早く考えてるんです
強力な速さで 考えているんだけど
本人は何考えてるか本人もわかりませんけれど
言葉に出ないんです まああんた聞いてますかね
まあさんに連絡なくちゃいけないんだけど
まあはいはい わかりましたっていうぐらいの言葉しか出てこない
頭の中でずっと言葉は走っている
そうやって基本的な妄想
あんまりにも喋る人は何型ですかね
言葉に粘土でも叩いておきたいほど喋る人々です
言葉ではない口の長い粘土でも置いても
どうしても止まらないように喋ると
あるいはちょっと個人個人で見なきゃわからないんですね
なんであんなに喋るかって
この中では 6つのカテゴリーにハマることがちょっと難しいんです
で ほとんどこの種類がありますね
あの知りたいことを知ってることいっぱいあって
これはちゃんと言っておかなきゃということで
もう喋ると 喋る喋ると
それ一つ もう一つは もう悪い方向にとしてはものすごく
もうもう自分では何も
何だかんださっぱりわからないし
自分としてはすごく不安でしょうし
ですからもうずっと喋る
そこで言葉でわかるんです
知りたいことはいっぱいあって
知っておいて喋っておかなきゃ
まあこれ喋っておかなきゃね
みんなまあ心配やというか
喋る人々は内容はあるんです
[咳]精神的に不安定でも
ただ喋るだけだったら同じことを大体四回
六回 十回 二十回でも繰り返す必要がある
だから二十回繰り返すまでは私は待ちません
私は一回言ったことは
また「だって」と言って次に始まるでしょう
もう君もう反抗してるんです
あんたそれね 十回繰り返すんだと
その通りになっちゃうんです
私にとってその時間もったいないんですね
それこうやって聞いていなくちゃいけないんだから
だから先まで聞いているんです
だから この それであの
言いたいものがたくさんあって喋る人っていうのは
やっぱり他のことに心がいっちゃったら
その人次に言ってること分からなくなっちゃうんですね
だから まあどういう性格かな
まあそれなかなかね 時々またよく喋る人
私が知ってる人々の中では偉いんですね
その自分の立場がね 社会では
周りにいる人々はやっぱり自分のまあ下の人々なんですね
だからその人々の面倒を見てあげなくちゃいけないんですね
一番偉い立場にいるんだから
ものすごくかわいそうな立場にいるんですね
みんなの面倒を見てあげなくちゃいけない
料理作っている人であろうが
事務所の手伝いする人であろうが
自分の鞄持ってくる人であろうが
だからスキル担当している人であろうか
だからいつでもみんなと何か喋っている
それで もうちょっと時代
ちょっと前のは先生たちもそんな感じなんですね
先生のうちにどんな用事があって行っても
君は何の用事で来たんですか？という質問さえも出てこないんです
それで先生がね 君 この間なんとかなんとかさんがね
こうこうこう言って それでこうこういうことで
あの だからあんたね あのテキストでなんとか人がこういうこと言ってるの知ってますかねとか言ってきません
が そうですね それちょっと知った方がいいですよと言って
そうやって三分先生のうちに行ったならば
もう三十分のいろんな膨大な授業を受けてもう帰ったことになっちゃうんです
でも決して生徒にとっては決して悪いことではない
授業外の話だから もっと立派に真面目に喋るし
聞きやすいし 覚えやすいし
それでその授業は研究枠組み以外のいろんな人生に必要な情報
知識やら得られるし そこで損するのはせっかく何のために来たかとか
肝心の目的を忘れた可能性あるかもしれませんだけど
そうやって喋る人々もいるんですね
だからその場合は性格分析はたまに気をつけてしなくちゃいけないんです
そこでこのどうだい 私の話しぶりは？っていう感じで喋る人は当然浴型なんですね
この漫才とかね 冗談言ったりとかね
面白いストーリー エピソード言ったりとか
みんな笑わせたりとかね
綺麗な発音さ 美しい日本語で語るとかね
そういうところに精を入れると
美しい日本語を語るのはいいんだけど
性格も美しいかね？かってちょっと調べなくちゃいけないんですね
だから言葉だけ大変丁寧っていうとこで
そこでまあ浴衣なんです
性格はもう小さい時から叩き込まれて洗練されてできていて
それで日本語は当たり前で
大変丁寧な日本語になる
それはものすごくわかるんですね
その人の日常茶飯事の言葉だと
その敬語やらあだこ使うのもね
そうやってこの人の話し方
話し方からも判断はできるんだけど
これそれなりに苦労しないとわからないんです
だからカンマターナをもらう場合は
先生のところでまあ一年
二年ぐらいやっぱりお手伝いしなくちゃいけないんです
それでなんとかわかって
先生がわかってきます
正統ではなく 昔はそうやって瞑想教えたんですね
まず瞑想教えてくださいと言っても
初めとは言いません そうすると
あの 何といいますか 泊まらせてくださいと
で いいですよというところで泊まってあげたんだから
朝から晩までいろいろ決まりありますからね
そうやって先生のお世話を片っ端からまずやる
それからどんどん先生の仕事を頼むようになると
まあそれでじわじわじわじわと
お互いに明確に心の隅から隅まで警戒するようにして
それで先生の方がね あなたずっとこのお寺の札付き係ばっかしでね
ちょっと瞑想でもできたらどうですかというふうに言うんです
先生は札付きから正統をね
卒業してあげて 瞑想の方を教えてあげる
その場合はぴったし合うんです
瞑想の方 で 時間かかるんです
だから卒業と同時に瞑想法を教えてくれる
そこで瞑想は自分一人で独立してやるんですね
そこでまあ時々教えてくれたりはしますけど
それで瞑想成功すれば
もう完璧にもう独立している一人前の人だからね
ですから 瞑想を教えてもらった瞬間からもう一人前なんです
だから瞑想修行自体は
自分がなんか自分の研究論文を書いているような感じなんです
もう研究論文書けるんだということを全部資料を集めてまとめて全部あって
話し合って 先生とどんな結論を出すかとかね
それでまあそろそろ論文出しちゃえばというところになったところで
もう別に行って 自分がちゃんと書いて書いて書いてもう書いてると
それで論文出したところに
もうまあちゃんと博士になって大学卒業しましたと
そういう博士になったところで
私の正統だ 私の正統だということはもうとっくに亡くなってるんですね
もう一人前の大人だからね
博士論文書くの で そんなような形なんですね
感覚としては 瞑想の世界というのは
だから瞑想を教えてもらうということでも
卒業させても追い出されても独立させているということ
瞑想成功したならば もう論文もちゃんと出しますって
受けましたと 認められたということ
そういうことで結構時間かかるもので
性格理解するためには昔は結構
で 遠い昔の話なんですけど
もしかすると六年や七十年前の話かもしれませんだけど
まあ私は勉強した時はこのあるお坊さんがクラスの中で授業中言ったストーリーで
自分の先生 があまりにも田舎もんで古い坊さんだと
そこで自分のお寺にどこかからこの子供一人連れてきたんです
親が お願いしますから
その子を出家させて育ててください
だからまあいいやと言って
それだけで 子供はお寺に泊まったんですね
そこでもう何年も経つんだけど
このお坊さんはまあじゃあそろそろ出家しましょうという話にならない
いつでもお寺の札付きばっかしやって
その子はお寺にいる で
差し上げても どうせあの寺出る男であろうが
出家してやるとか みんなに勉強はさせますけど
だから無駄にはなりませんね
ものすごく厳密に勉強はさせますけど
弟子にするという話はない
それである日 この我々はこのガムの代わりに遊びで噛むある木の実があります
それはもう皮がついていて
刃物でちゃんと皮を抜いて綺麗にして切って割って
かなり硬いんですけどね
皮なくちゃいけないんですね